okay so after the explosive euphoria
season 2 finale we have many many
questions about the fates of the
characters though we've already made an
ending explained video that talked about
the season as a whole but this breakdown
i wanted to discuss the unanswered
questions whilst also giving off
theories for season three now that the
finale left rue being clean and sober
once more the rest of the characters are
in shambles with most of their
storylines being left up in the air many
of them are open-ended and the first
question i want to address is what
happened to fares fae and ash i know a
lot of you think that there's still hope
for the latter because we didn't see his
body but the surrounding elements of the
scene seem to hint that he is indeed
dead now firstly we saw the red laser
light going up to his forehead and then
secondly we of course heard that
deafening shot during this scene fez was
also screaming out that he was just a
kid and if we look at things from a
narrative point of view it also makes
sense that ash would be killed bez was
very much a guardian to him and though
he tried to steer him down a certain
path it's clear that he wouldn't listen
ash just had a switch in his head that
he couldn't turn off and this made him
kill mouse and also go toe-to-toe with a
swat even though fez said that he'd take
the fall so therefore i think ash is
dead and though yeah they could bring
him back it would be a bit stupid if
they did just from a narrative point of
view now as affairs his fate remains up
in the air but i do think there are
several directions that they can take
things firstly we know that custer was
working with the police after mouse's
death to get fez put away the other our
theory is that he died too due to being
shot in the gunfire exchange we do see
him being handcuffed and then picked up
by the police it was sad to see his note
alexi or bloodstain like his suit which
they lovingly decreased for him and i
just hope she knows how to wash blood
stains out of it too
so sorry a bit bit too soon now fez was
originally supposed to be killed off in
season one but he was kept around and
he's very much become a fan favorite
there are definitely two directions that
they can take the character with the
first of these being that he gets jail
time the season opened with the story of
his childhood and it very much ended
with the consequences of this including
a small shot of grandma lying in her bed
therefore him being escorted away would
be a fitting end for his arc and it
would also make a lot of sense for the
show as he could finally move away from
the addiction themes and focus on rue
being sober however there is a chance
that fez can get out and it could be a
bonus that custer tried recording him
with two devices whilst one was put in a
drinks cup the other remained behind and
this could potentially clear fears of
custer's murder he'd be on the recording
trying to cover for ash into the face
quick thinking the story she gave custer
would clear fez's name bears is also a
carer to his grandma who's sick in bed
and this might grant him some leeway i
can see there being potential that he's
allowed to be under house arrest in
order to look after her as she is a
dependent and therefore he could argue
that he's a carer now whilst the drug
story line could be closed off if bez is
sent away one lingering thread remains
that is what will laurie do over the
debt that roost allows to hit now we
know that rue suitcase had over ten
thousand dollars worth of narcotics in
it and that she admitted to laurie that
it had been flushed though softly spoken
laurie was furious and she then drugged
rue and locked her in a room after
dubbing her up with morphine blurry
means business and the fact that rue has
escaped from her has only paused the
issue has of trying to fund the missing
drugs whilst faye tried to implicate
laurie in mouse's murder at the start of
the episode the suitcase of damocles is
still hanging over roo's head if laurie
doesn't end up in jail then she will
note our pursue for the rest of the cash
or force her into human trafficking like
she implied now due to the end of
episode narration roo says that she
stayed sober so laurie hasn't come
knocking yet but it's only a matter of
time laurie has a lot of connections and
will be desperate for the money no doubt
that roo will be able to pay her back
financially therefore they might go down
the dark and twisted trafficking route
with laurie attempting to get a cash
back through other means there's
potential here that they might do a
really messed up storyline but i'm
actually kind of hoping that they don't
and instead i pray that lori is captured
by the authorities in the final
narration rue talks about how she
remained sober for the rest of the year
and if laurie had have come knocking i
think this would have been brought up
too now this narration also gives us an
idea of what happened to roo and jules
after the play rue says jules was my
first love i like to remember it that
way with was being the big word that's
signaling they didn't get back together
rue rebuffed useless attempts at
reconciliation after the play and walked
off on a path to sobriety actually when
encountered the steps here and was
hoping that she'd take exactly 12 but
alas over a decade of marvel movies has
made me start to look for easter eggs
that on there i'm sorry however this
somewhat reflects the ending of season 1
as it was jewels who left here but now
rue is the one leaving this very toxic
cycle roo needs to focus on herself now
and her attempts to stay clean which as
we know from the narration did indeed
work the emotional toll of their
relationship led to her relapsing and
without having to maintain this she
clearly worked on her sobriety now if
you're enjoying the video so far we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up and
also don't forget to subscribe to the
channel i had a weird glitch with the
first ending explain we did where
youtube basically shadow banned the
video from the search engine after it
got copyright claimed by hbo they
completely hid it from my channel and
after i got in touch with them they said
it was an indexing issue but as of this
recording it is still gone i did upload
another version but i lost a lot of
views so the love is always appreciated
and it really means a lot if you support
us by just hitting that thumbs up button
now back to the video and another
question is will elliot and roo become
friends once again the pair met at the
new year's party under the influence of
many substances and continued to take
drugs together despite jewels thinking
roo was sober jules's distrust of eliot
was correct as he enabled rue's drug
taking but it was clear elliot wasn't as
addicted as she was however in the
finale roo forgives him for accidentally
saving her life but the question still
remains will i become friends once more
to me it's highly unlikely as he enabled
her drug use and being around drug users
isn't good for her recovery however she
very much seems at peace with him which
is why she gives him a nod at lexi's
play she's not his enemy but she isn't
really his friend either it's just
someone that's popped up in her life and
she now uses him as an example of what
to stay away from now whilst elia and
roo's friendship is over there is
possibility of jules and ellia becoming
an item just like real life adding the
drama of this would present challenges
to rude's recovery and seeing how she
handles this would make for some really
interesting television the alien jewels
character could end up being used to
explore addiction once more but it just
depends if they want to go that way or
not agile's has sort of validation meant
for a while so after his rejection of a
reconciliation she might have sought
comfort and eliot knowing that he's into
her that's just my theory but obviously
let me know below if you disagree now
the reactions to the play blew wide open
some relationships with cassie seeking
to publicly embarrass her sister like
she'd been because of the portrayal of
nate he dumped her and cassie decided to
finally become the joker she took to the
stage and aired out the issue she had
with her sister which led to cassie
chasing her through the school now
whilst lexi was cheered to the point
that she came back on stage and
continued the play it's clear that the
relationship with her sister is in
tatters whether they can reconcile
remains to be seen but i do hope they
can last episode we saw the trauma from
their past and how they both handle it
in different ways with lexi retreating
into herself whilst cassie sought solace
in relationships we don't see the
sisters talk after the play but season 3
should see them attempt to repair their
sisterly bond as they've been through so
much together now towards the end of the
episode we do see the aftermath of the
cat fight between maddie and cassie with
cassie having a bloody face in
disheveled hair whilst muddy nurses are
cut on her foot cassie explains how
bittersweet the fight was as she tells
maddie how nate dumped her she's very
much at her wits end as she's made a
scene out of herself and doesn't even
have nate to console her this is when
mario explains that this is just the
start of it now this is an interesting
line but what does it actually mean well
initially i took it to be something that
meant maddie was going to keep
tormenting her and throughout the season
nate warned cassie that she wouldn't
ever stop due to the gun moment in the
bedroom it's clear that maddie would be
putting herself in a lot of danger if
she ever tackled him head-on and thus i
assumed it meant that she was gonna ruin
cassie's life however after reading
comments from you guys and reflecting on
it i think maddie is saying that this is
just the start of nate tormenting cassie
she has of course been through the ring
with nate and knows what he's like
therefore she would be aware that this
is only the beginning and that cassie is
bound to go through it too if that is
what maddie is saying then it seems that
there may be a chance that they can stay
friends again after this is all blown
over now this is because maddie may have
learned from the tale of her employer
who told her that she never reconciled
with a friend whose boyfriend she slept
with therefore i hope that she really
uses this as a lesson and will be there
as a shoulder to cry on when nate
eventually breaks cassie's heart again
but speaking of nate what will he do
next well in the finale he sought
revenge and got his father put in jail
by exposing his recordings to the police
it seems his ambition was simply revenge
but with his father in jail for whatever
was on that flash drive it puts the
business at jeopardy in episode six of
season two it was said how nightcares
about inheriting it and that cal sex
life would ruin any chances of that with
cal arrested it's no doubt he will go to
jail and be put on a certain register
for illegally filming sex acts however i
do think the business will survive it'll
just need a rebrand and hopefully this
makes nate finally realize all of the
wrongs that he's done after going to see
jewels i think he might have omitted her
video from that flash drive to protect
her and potentially the business due to
her being underage there's lots of
possibilities with it but it does seem
like nader's finally done with this and
though i don't think he deserves a
redemption arc there are different ways
that they can take things in the future
that they'll probably go down because
this is what television shows do now
sadly understand this season was cat who
at least had a storyline unlike the
silent member of maddie's crew cat had a
very interesting storyline that saw her
find a boyfriend two nights in vanilla
whilst she yearned for a toxic
relationship like the other girls it was
a gripping storyline complete with a
moment which she was visually
overwhelmed by competing female
ideologies we saw her return to her
webcam ways briefly in episode 7 in a
montage and it's clear that she'll be
seeking out someone toxic for her life
hopefully they can resolve the behind
the scenes beef between barbie and sam
if it's still lingering and we can see
more of cat as she definitely deserves
the spotlight anyway that's our video
and hopefully we answered some of your
questions and you enjoyed our theories
on where things could be going if you
want to watch your ending explain then
that will be linked on screen right now
and hopefully i'll see you over there
right after this without the way thanks
for clicking this i've been paul you've
been the best i'll see you on the next
one take care peace